nous sommes situés devant l'entreprise
games et kahui en cours une société de
18 collaborateurs engagés dans la
fabrication de pièces de prototypes dans
le secteur de l'automobile et du pétrole
venez on va rencontrer isabelle chaillot
sakho dirigeante
bonjour
bonjour isabelle chaillot bonjour
alors qu'est ce qui se passe chez gam et
4 qu'est ce qu'on vous fait concrètement
au quotidien alors du centre spécialisé
dans la mécanique de précision nous
fabriquons des pièces façon selon des
plans dans des matières différentes que
ce soit du métal au plastique plutôt
dans les secteurs de l'automobile du
pétrole donc tous travaillant dans les
secteurs de l'industrie avec les grands
acteurs de l'automobile
du pétrole de la r&d également de
l'aéronautique et
avec des start up dans lequel deux
faisons confiance alors des secteurs que
vous avez mentionné ces des secteurs qui
ont été très impacté par la crise
sanitaire
comment vous l'avez ressenti vous y
serez écoutez là c'est vrai que ça nous
a beaucoup affectés
nous anticipons une grosse baisse d'ici
la fin de l'année et encore moins en
moins 30%
c'est une crise qui est durable mais
nous espérons vraiment rebondir l'année
prochaine et nous avons
nous avons travaillé sur en interne de
nouveaux axes stratégiques des axes
stratégiques qui vont être accompagnés
par la région ile de france puisque dans
le cadre de son plan de relance
industrie la région ile de france vous
accorde une subvention de 350 millions
euros oui tout à fait donc on souhaite
justement remercier la région ile de
france qui va nous accompagner dans les
annes trois années qui viennent sur le
développement et les investissements de
de la société il nous avons deux axes
forts en termes de taxes stratégiques
c'est-à-dire que premièrement nous avons
décidé de revoir notre stratégie est
d'investir vraiment dans l'est dans les
industries fort notamment tout ce qui
est industries
médicales et pharmaceutiques puisqu'ils
industries agroalimentaires on voudrait
également se développer l'amplifier
industrie
verte notamment dans l'hydrogène mais
également dans tout ce qui est armements
et défense est également accompagné les
start up dans le puits ce qui est
robotique
l'axé de développement l'autre c'est
vraiment d'investir dans le numérique
puisque on voudrait devenir un des
leaders dans notre industrie 4.0 non
seulement dans tout ce qui est un outil
industriel de pointe est également
accompagné par des recrutements le
personnel et sont plus investir dans les
jeunes de demain qui puisse accompagner
le
de l'industrie merci isabelle faille au
présent titre co dirigeante de
l'entreprise gamme et cas située à
guyancourt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]